you'll never get the truth from a
current extremist
their whole job is to lie to you
and to spend things their own way
which is why i say if you want the truth
talk to a former extremist
you still have the jacket still have the
jacket
oh so this was cash chicago area
skinheads which was that first american
uh neo-nazi group and then on the back
final solution final solution was my
band name with the 88 which is kind of
shorthand uh for the eighth letter of
the alphabet hh which stands for heil
hitler what was the final solution
well the final solution in my mind was
the same thing that was in hitler's mind
and that was the extermination of the
jews that was the ultimate solution
from the age of 14 to 22 christian
piccolini helped build america's first
neo-nazi skinhead organization
but today he has devoted his life to
helping people disengage from the same
extremist groups he used to belong to
what i see when i look at those pictures
is not a tough guy i see a very
insecure
low self-esteem
and broken young man
and i think it's important for people to
understand that what draws people to
those movements hate movements is not
the ideology initially nobody is born to
hate it's something that we learn
and for me i was searching for an
identity a community and a purpose
christian was ripe for radicalization
and on a street corner in 1987 he was
approached by a skinhead leader and
recruited on the spot
that man
told me that i mattered nobody had ever
told me that before i bought into the
ideas that they put in my head because
it made me feel powerful with me today
chris piccolini 19 years old director of
the illinois chapter of the northern
hammer skinheads well i believe we're
warriors today and we're fighting for a
great cause which is the white race i
noticed my life changed immediately i
went from somebody who
had been bullied to now somebody who was
feared
christian describes his radicalization
as a descent into a community of
like-minded individuals
they consumed a potent mix of race-based
conspiracy theories and misinformation
that fueled their anger and justified
their attacks
i wonder how that radicalization process
compares to
my today it was very face to face
but what's happened now
is the internet has kind of become that
digital alley that i was recruited in
except it's an all-you-can-eat 24-hour
hate buffet
and there are millions and millions of
young people like i was at 14 years old
what about the el paso shooter the whole
idea of a lone wolf is a misnomer uh
while there are white supremacists who
may never in real life meet another
white supremacist but it doesn't mean
they're not connected
the internet is a technological game
changer amplifying lies and weaponizing
propaganda like never before
extremists are flooding social media and
encrypted chat forums
creating an alternate universe of
imaginary threats
where lies become truth and conspiracy
becomes reality
as of may 2021
facebook banned 250 groups
linked to white supremacy
often what starts as edgy memes that
target young men on platforms like
reddit twitter and others
quickly spirals into more extreme
content
the el paso shooter for example wrote
that he was inspired by a manifesto
posted online by a shooter in new
zealand who live-streamed himself
murdering 51 muslims
called the great replacement this
manifesto justified the killings as a
defense of white culture from the
existential threat posed by muslims
minorities and immigrants
the fact that these white genocide fears
have been debunked time and again over
centuries means little online
within the echo chamber of the movement
the new zealand shooter's manifesto is
revered and used to indoctrinate new
recruits
all too often that's how it works the
speed of online radicalization helps
explain why race-based attacks are on
the rise
as christian said
nobody is born to hate
it's learned
[Music]